es ist eine unglaubliche röntgen und
radio blase sie ist das überbleibsel
einer gigantischen explosion weltraum
deren ausmaß selbst die forschungswelt
verblüfft sie übersteigt die bisher
bekannte rekord explosion um ein
fünffaches und war die stärkste dies
seit dem urteil gegeben hat der auslöser
dafür war vermutlich ein supermassives
schwarzes loch ist dieser kasse beinahe
urknall nur ein einzelfall klicks um
science-fiction gibt's übrigens jetzt
auch als podcast und zwar auch täglich
die links dafür zu spotify und apple
sind und in der video beschreibung also
los geht's herzlich willkommen
etwa 390 millionen lichtjahre von der
erde entfernt liegt der galaxienhaufen
of wie ups der neben dem galaxien auch
energiereiches intergalaktisches plasma
enthält er strahlt als zweitältester
röntgenquelle am himmel und das zentrum
des galaxienhaufens ist darin als
kühlere dichte zone zu erkennen vor
einigen jahren wurde dort mit hilfe des
chandra röntgenteleskop der nasa eine
ungewöhnliche entdeckung gemacht ein
teil des strahlenden plasmas ist am rand
extrem eingedellt
es sieht so aus als würde dort eine
große leere blase das energiereiche gas
verdrängt
es ist bereits bekannt dass solche
dellen entstehen können wenn
beispielsweise das schwarze loch in
einem sogenannten angie einem aktiven
galaxienkernen einen ausbruch hatte was
aber neu ist ist das extreme ausmaße
dieser delle um solch eine immense
konnte also delle zu erzeugen bräuchte
ist ein vielfaches der energie die man
von den bisher stärksten ausbrüchen
kennen so eine explosion müsste das
kühle zentrum des galaxienhaufens
einfach wegpusten forschende am navarro
research laboratories in washington dc
sind jetzt der frage nachgegangen wie
diese riesen blase entstanden sein
könnte dafür nutzten sie eine ganze
reihe extrem leistungsstarke
radioteleskope in den usa australien und
indien das ergebnis hat selbst die
fachwelt schockiert der krater der
explosion ist so groß dass unsere
gesamte milchstraße 15 mal hineinpassen
würde der koautor maxima kewitsch vom
goddard space flight center der nasa
sagt selbst dort muss eine eruption von
beispiellosen ausmaß stattgefunden haben
obwohl dieser ausbruch alles bisher
bekannte bei weitem übertroffen hat ist
die explosion eines supermassereichen
schwarzen
im zentrum einer galaxie wohl die
wahrscheinlichste erklärung das
räumliche zusammentreffen der röntgen
blase und des gigantischen radio lappens
deutet darauf hin dass es sich um ein
fossil eines enormen angie ausbruchs
handelt warum der ausbruch so gigantisch
groß war können die forscher noch nicht
sagen vermutlich rus die schockwellen
der explosion aber schon seit 240
millionen jahren durch den galaxien
cluster abgesehen davon dass die
explosionen die mit abstand größte war
die je festgestellt werden konnte wirft
sie auch weitere fragen auf der galaxien
kern der diesen ausbruch verursacht
haben könnte ist mittlerweile eher ruhig
er besitzt nicht einmal jets
ausstrahlung oder teilchen es könnte
aber sein dass dieser angie früher viel
aktiver gewesen ist wirklich erstaunlich
ist auch dass bisher nur eine einzige
explosions blase gefunden wurde denn
normalerweise erzeugt ein angie ausbruch
symmetrische jets im radio blasen auf
beiden seiten des galaxien kerns die
forscher vermuten dass das gegenstück
auf der anderen seite in ein weniger
dichtes kosmisches medium geraten und
dort vollständig verblasst ist außerdem
ist das außergewöhnlich dass der kern
des galaxienhaufen so eine krasse
explosion überhaupt überstanden hat in
anderen clustern wurden die zentren
durch die ausbrüche völlig in stücke
gerissen nicht so im aufwuchs clustern
und noch ein fakt sorgt für fragende
gesichter unter den forschenden die mega
explosion hat sich extrem langsam
sozusagen in zeitlupe abgespielt
insgesamt erstreckte sich über hunderte
von millionen von jahren
damit geht das spektakel an den rand
unserer vorstellungskraft in astronomie
fachkreisen hält man es nun für möglich
dass es noch weitere solcher mega
explosionen gegeben hat die in zukunft
noch aufgespürt werden kann man einem
schwarzen loch entkommen anklicken
anschauen und neugier zum abonnieren
sehr cooler kanal bis dann bleibt dran